[Musique]
c'est vrai
une captation vidéo à huis clos pour la
chanteuse sara jade l'occasion de
présenter son concert fruit de quatre
jours de travail en résidence à la
batterie de bianco ça nous a permis sur
les deux premiers jours de faire
vraiment de la création pure musical
aussi la création lumières et sons on a
monté tout un spectacle qui lui va durer
à peu près à venir 15h30
en plus des musiques déjà présente dans
son ep sorti en février dernier et
retravaillés pour l'occasion
sara jade a créé quatre nouveaux mans
[Musique]
je les écris il ya un petit moment déjà
j'avais jamais encore eu l'occasion de
la craie dans son intégralité mais c'est
une chanson qui a été écrite après les
attentats du bataclan assez intense
voilà beaucoup d'intensité
très rock très rentre dedans un peu
énervé ce qui était un petit peu mon
état d'esprit du moment quand j'ai écrit
ce morceau une heure et demie
d'enregistrement intense avec pour seul
bémol l'absence du public
aujourd'hui on a fait une captation
vidéo mais c'est vrai que le public nous
manque donc ont hâte de le retrouver en
6ème le but de la résidence est vraiment
de créer le spectacle dans son
intégralité avec le son la lumière les
nouveaux morceaux pour pouvoir ensuite
le présenter aux programmateurs des
salles de spectacles et puis pour
pouvoir nous
nous produira sur scène dans des
endroits ils ont droit qui voudront bien
de nous en attendant d'autres
rendez-vous sara jade et son groupe se
reproduiront à la batterie avec du
public cette fois le 12 juin prochain
[Musique]